you know me I love a good civilization
game this review is so late oh my god so
it will better late than never
holy [ __ ] two weeks like though
civilization beyond Earth
so civilization beyond Earth is the
newest civilization game you know me I
love those two billa's Asian games you
start out of civilization it starts out
small and then you build everything you
build buildings you build an army you
built an economy in this new game
civilization beyond Earth you're not on
earth anymore hence the title you have
found it another planet now you go down
there with new technology you're not
starting from the ground up it's not
like oh we need to discover explosives
you don't find gunpowder on this new
planet you have all the technology that
got you to a new planet so now you're
researching new things advanced things
even your explorers are like in a rover
unit I thought that was really cool it
was a leap forward nose like a right
fresh new civilization experience and it
kind of is and it's still fun but it's
not without flaws first of all if you're
looking for that civilization experience
was just like oh just one more turn I
was one more turning myself from
midnight to 4:00 a.m. last night they're
gonna get that in this game it's just
that addictive that's how a civilization
game works and this does feel fresh and
new I mean just right out the gate
there's gas over the tiles really I
can't do anything on that tile until I
clear the gas so I need the technology
that takes out the gas there are these
aliens on the planet they're kind of
sentient they're like the heart of the
swarm and Chevys they're sentient but
you're not gonna sit down and have tea
with them the whole thing is like oh
they're not aggressive if you don't
attack them that is true unless you send
an explorer out there in which case I
like cat well he's dead which is really
frustrating because in any other game if
a sentient civilization killed one of
your guys you're like we're at war for
some odd reason these [ __ ] get a
pass on that I don't get that we have
three different affinities that you
build your civilization tours we're
gonna call them orange blue and red
because they are in fact orange blue and
red all right guys here it is advice
from me to you right out the gate at the
beginning of the game first chance you
get put one point into red after that
the aliens won't kill your explorers
anymore and you'll be fine boom but
these three paths were really cool I was
like alright how I play the game
determines how your civilization grows I
myself was going for the contact ending
so you need like affinity and I believe
the levels thirteen to get the endgame
thing so I was level thirteen harmony
going right for my contact ending but
everyone was closing in on my borders
they were like but the thing this color
code level affects the most in the game
is in fact
you're military and had enough money so
I just bought a bunch of units and
they're all these huge badass heart of
the swarm looking alien hybrid soldiers
I'm right to the border I'll look try it
they're all like sure that's right you
go away you go cry it off that's the
thing is that the game really doesn't
have a lot of balance in it if you're
kicking ass one way you're pretty much
kicking the entire game's ass and that's
what I learned early on Azhar okay so in
the technology tree that you look at its
new [ __ ] oh my god yellow technology
tree you look out you're like okay I
kind of grasp what it is that's what
you're like I want hovercraft aw [ __ ] um
okay my economic adviser says that's
good for the alright we'll do that
that's good for the economy we'll just
stick with that really confusing at
first and then the next few times you
play the game but I learned early on
anything that has one of the color
symbols just uniform it go for one color
symbol all the time you just get those
technologies or Army's going to be
pretty unstoppable and no one's gonna
mess over it and it also gets you
towards the end game so that's fun and
in this civilization game I just wish
you had more interaction with the other
civilizations see interactions like hey
you want to do a cooperation agreement
and maybe next time okay I guess I'll
talk to you when you need materials
peace and that's that I wanted to feel
like a closeness to at least one
civilization tell me small talk can't we
just talk about the Seahawks and share
gamers be like all right yeah it's
baseball that's fun did you catch the
game last night Oh in hell of a game
hello game I guess they would do that if
they had cultural buildings and
recreational buildings that you can
build in this game but it felt like the
culture and the recreation and
everything like it was just gone for
every step up this game did to try
something new that was really cool there
are a couple steps back that they also
do city states are gone I love city
states and civilization 5 they're these
outposts that are like husks of cities
days from civilization 5 but they don't
do what city-states did in Civilization
5 you create a path to a Mueller all
right give me my buff right I'm out it
feels like I'm shooting on this game I
really don't mean to [ __ ] on this game I
had a lot of fun playing it it's just a
fun game to play
it's civilization man and it's another
world and the world looks great and the
music is awesome there are new
interactions new hurdles to overcome new
ways to interact like you have favors in
this game I heard favors were this huge
saying what this one guy was like hey
can you give me five energy every turn
and in return you get a favor from me I
heard these were like trump cards like
boom pay the favor I stacked three
favors with this one this dude owed me
three favors I was nice and [ __ ] I just
needed one material later on the game
like okay I'm calling my favorite he's
like no doesn't work for me I was like
okay I'm calling in all three favors I
just need five of that again it was like
mmm doesn't work for me what's the point
of doing favors easier just to build a
huge army take a city and then take the
material they implement a couple of
things that were in the civilization
five expansions like spies are huge in
this game as a big part of getting
technology or spies which was great I
didn't want to see spies go away so I'm
glad to see him in this one but the
whole cultural mechanic of a brave new
world not in this game the religion that
they had and one of the expansions not
in this game I'll say it like this if
you have not played a civilization game
you're like I'd like to play a
civilization game this game is going to
blow your mind like here here's what
people are raving about civilization
you're like but if you have a
civilization 5 and its expansions this
game is not any sort of leap forward
from that if you compare civilization
beyond Earth to civilization 5 and the
two expansions together civilization
beyond Earth is not to par with a
civilization 5 bundle think of Diablo 3
and then the Reaper of souls expansion
or at least the update that came out
before Reaper of souls that overhauled
the entire game mechanically between
Diablo 3 and that expansion is not as
big as civilization 5 - civilization
beyond Earth I'm telling me I could see
civilization beyond Earth being an
expansion to civilization 5 here's my
next bit of advice team winter sales are
coming winter is coming my friends and
steam is giving it to us I imagine
civilization beyond Earth will go on
sale in the steam winter sale when it
does sure it's definitely worth picking
up and in that I will say civilization
beyond Earth is worth buying at sale
price get it on sale you'll be happy as
hell but if you have civilization 5 and
its expansions then you get this at full
game price you're gonna be like I I have
more with my civilization 5 bundle or so
civilization beyond Earth have you
played it what did you think about it
how do you think it compares to
civilization 5 whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more